the feud between President Trump and
Omarosa turning into a no-holds-barred
back-and-forth Trump campaign filing an
arbitration action against the former
White House aide alleging breach of a
nondisclosure agreement the president
also taken aim at Omarosa
on Twitter writing when you give a
crazed crying lowlife a break and give
her a job at the White House I guess it
just didn't work out good work by
general Kelly for quickly firing that
dog Omarosa is responding with a new
round of personal attacks against the
president it's interesting that he's
trying to silence me so what is he
trying to hide what is he afraid of if
he hadn't said anything that was
derogatory or demeaning to African
Americans and women why would he go to
this extent to try to shut me should be
should he be afraid of more tapes that
you have in your possession I think he
should be afraid of being exposed as the
misogynist the dignity and the races
that he is you were instructed according
to your book to bring up the emails at
every point you could at the end of the
20 2016 Hillary Clinton's email yes that
was our talker did Donald Trump know
about those emails before they came out
absolutely he is unfit to be in this
office and to service the presidency and
press secretary Sarah Sanders is
rebutting on roses claims watch I think
the president is certainly voicing his
frustration with the fact that this
person has shown a complete lack of
integrity particularly by the actions
following her time here at the White
House the president wanted to give her a
chance and he made clear when General
Kelly came on and he voiced concerns
that this individual what didn't have
the best interest of the White House and
the president in the country at heart
the president said do what you can to
get along and if you can't it gave him
full authority to carry out the decision
to let her go this has absolutely
nothing to do with race and everything
to do with the president calling out
someone's lack of integrity the idea
that you would only point a few of the
things that the president has said
negative about people that are
minorities the fact is the president's
an equal-opportunity
person that calls things like he sees it
he always fights fire with fire and he
certainly doesn't hold back on doing
that across the board so what Sara
Sanders was talking about as a series of
tweets that the where the president has
used similar language I think we have a
few of them if we could call them up for
example Mitt Romney had his chance to
beat a failed president but he choked
like a dog now he calls me a racist but
I am least racist person there is tweet
number two Robert Pattinson should not
take back Kristen Stewart she cheated on
him like a dog and will do it again just
watch you can do much better and tweet
number three
I'm little at McMiller I'm now going to
teach you a big boy lesson about
lawsuits and finance you ungrateful dog
but then to advance a story just a
little bit because this was what
everyone is talking about
Omarosa makes a claim that the president
was on tape saying the n-word now
there's been back and forth of whether
this ever existed take a listen to Sarah
Sanders answering this question from our
reporter the American people they'll
never hear I can't guarantee anything
but I can tell you that the president
addressed this question directly I can
tell you that I've never heard it okay
so here we are day I guess three of the
Omarosa Trump view it will end everybody
it will end but for now this is a hot in
the news and so Jesse let me go to you
about how everybody's handling this well
I think the median Omarosa are perfect
for each other they both have very
little credibility they're both
flip-floppers and they both hate
President Trump I don't trust anything
she says she's a serial fabricator she
should never have been hired for her job
at the White House she belongs in
reality TV as a villain he should never
have hired the villain because obviously
she's a huge backstabber hours after she
was fired she gets on the phone and
starts lying to her friends and former
colleagues about why she was fired she
said she quit and then hours after she's
fired she comes up with this tape where
the president allegedly uses a racial
slur out of the blue funny the same day
she was fired she starts talking about
the tape that someone played her when
they asked the person who allegedly
played the tape he says I don't have a
tape I've never even heard about a tape
then she said Oh Frank Luntz has heard
the tape Frank Luntz comes out says I
don't know what you're talking about
so I've never heard a tape so she has
zero credibility at this point Trump
says he doesn't didn't say it at this
point you have to take him at his word
Mark Burnett the producer for The
Apprentice allegedly told the president
then there are no tapes that exist of
him saying this word her history in the
White House has been riddled with poor
performance Al Gore's office fired her
for I think she was in charge of
correspondence and it turns out they
found like 80,000 letters under her desk
that she never even sent back and then
they transferred over to the Clinton
team in commerce secretary's office and
they had to get rid of her because she
was an absolute personnel disaster this
is not a racial thing to call someone a
dog the list goes on and on he's called
Glenn Beck a dog Ted Cruz David Gregory
Arianna Huffington and I think Sarah
Sanders said the right thing today when
she was confronted about the racial
issue she said in one and a half years
Donald Trump has created 700,000 jobs
for african-americans in this country
and in eight years President Barack
Obama had only created 195 thousand
dollars I just let that speak for itself
well I'll give you the next word then
well I just think that's pretty
ridiculous I mean the fact is that what
you see here is an economy has been
recovering it's been steadily recovering
black community still has twice the
unemployment of white community is he
taking any steps to deal with that let's
get to the dog thing because I think
this kind of the top of the news today
this is so deeply offensive I mean it's
one thing he's calling LeBron dumb he
goes after Don Lemon is dumb he goes
after black woman I can think of
Frederica Wilson Maxine Waters Susan
Rice Donna Brazile and now this thing I
just thought I don't care of your race
but I just think to call a woman a dog
in this way was so demeaning so beneath
the office of the presidency I worry
about just our kids I mean that you have
to say oh that's the president that's
the way he talks about a woman that he
disagrees with on some level I wonder
why is he engaging why would the
president engage with this person but
then you realize oh in some of these
tapes like we thought this stuff about
being fired in the White House Situation
Room by John Kelly back who's gonna
believe that but here
the tape then it with regard to the
n-word here comes she says people say oh
no such tape then Katrina Pierson and
others who were Trump aides say we never
had such a conversation with Omarosa
Omarosa produces a tape I'm thinking wow
so maybe there's something to it you say
she has no credibility I would agree
with you I would have agreed with you a
long time ago Jessie but she keeps
producing tapes that in fact back up her
story Kennedy is the president something
I guess in somewhat paying the price for
trying for being loyal to her and he
liked her apparently on the apprentice
he liked her spunk he liked it that she
was a villain that she would maybe turn
things up and get things done yeah I
mean sometimes you make a bad call she's
one of those unstable people that we all
have known whether it's in your work
life or your family life and these are
the people who hold situations hostage
and they always find a way to get in
there especially to the most powerful
person who can you serve any of their
enemies around them and and right the
wrongs that have been done before them
and so the president obviously is a
loyal person look at some of the people
that he's had on his campaign staff and
some of the people that he's hired and
the White House somewhat questionable
not all of them some of them are very
good hires but however here because it
was only loyalty that was that was the
only connection that they had because
you know no one really knows what her
area of expertise is you know we were
all sitting around here before the show
trying to figure out exactly what she
did even you know regardless of her
title and when someone who is loyal
feels betrayed that's when you see the
kind of reaction that the president is
displaying I do think it's a distraction
I think the story would go away and I
think he would actually come off more
sympathetic if he didn't engage her to
this level but he feels like he has to
push some of these feuds to this level
and I think you'll see in the future
instead of background checks in the
White House they're going to give psych
tests what about the list that Jesse had
of all the other people that the
president has called a dog well I'm in
fact I was like I agree with one 100% in
terms of the president should not be
saying these things this really is
beneath him when it comes to Omarosa one
I will point out she proved me right she
is a unifier she
brought me and Brian Stover from seeing
any other he used my quote on the show
on this thing so she Wow
oil and water this brought us together
but here's the thing about her she is a
bad human being her race and gender is
irrelevant
she's a manipulative evil mean person
the things that she says let's just say
we'll give it to her let's say our
president is mildly racist and when he
gets mad he says stereotypical things
you who claim to be the African American
watchdog for us in the White House not
only sod go down you did nothing about
it and you profited from it and it
wasn't until your poor work got you
fired that you saw our problems we're
trying to profit again she's not a dog
she's not any other by that she's a Tom
and that's way worse than anything else
it's also known him longer I mean she's
the one who's know she could have
stopped this the renewable mana probably
telling the truth yeah and throughout
the campaign name she has known him the
long and still conceivably if this was
his true character she's seen that
character she's been in the courtroom
when the cameras during the campaign and
she'd be in the greenroom so she'd be uh
not just at fox have been in other
places on other networks and we were
supposed to take her at her word and
take her seriously and have her on the
show and to promote Donald Trump and you
know now you do have to pay a price for
this I do want to ask you this Jesse
there is something to be said about
starving a story right like ignore her
consider her irrelevant it just just
move on and talk about all the good
things going on but does the president
one he'd probably that's not in his
nature to do that he likes to
counterpunch but also does he have some
ability to discredit her further by
being the one that's out there
discrediting her well yesterday we
talked about whether or not he should
completely ignore her the way he ignored
mm and I don't think the president is
capable of ignoring things when it
reaches this level when you have are
Barroso on CNN and MSNBC and even the
sunday shows going out wall the wall
like that I think the president has to
come back and has to come back hard and
when he might fire Gary yes he will use
the word dog and he will tweet about
five or six things but at the same time
I don't know if the story helps this
president there's a lot of other good
things going on I believe Germany is
blocked four hundred million dollars go
into Iran there's great things happening
in North Korea with the remains coming
back from our soldiers and what we're
talking about is this hysterical woman
who's humiliated herself in front of our
eyes and we're feeding this frenzy about
a tape that no one even knows exists and
probably doesn't exist and no one can
prove so she's just throwing stuff out
there and everyone's and that's why she
keeps coming up with tapes that's
there's no tape him using that way know
that you don't know that but he she
encounters it she records everything why
didn't she record when she did that I
don't know but I'm telling she's come up
with two tapes that people like you said
oh this can't exist this couldn't have
happened and it did have I don't know
what happened Jess she's not Credle
Jesse you know who has it was not
credible you know who lacks credibility
was a president Trump I think she was
fired three times four times you know
who hired her four times yeah
Donald Trump what's wrong we're fighting
we're all Dumber for this conversation
absolutely we're arguing over something
she wants regardless if there's a tape
or not tape
she's a worse person if there is a table
well I'm just saying I don't give her
any credibility tires but isn't it
interesting that all of us who doubt her
keep coming back said oh my god she has
a tape of this